messieurs bonsoir adieu cowboys adieu
john wayne a nommé passé à hollywood il
est passé pendant près d'un demi siècle
et il a fait du bien au cinéma il fait
du bien aussi à notre besoin de rêve
john wayne 72 ans a fini par lâcher
prise cette nuit à los angeles
la maladie a gagné le cancer contre
lequel il luttait depuis 15 ans a fini
par l'abattre et tout le monde est
triste
la chevauchée fantastique le massacre de
fort apache l'homme tranquille rio
grande baie il ya comme ça plus de 200
films des bons et des mauvais et qui
nous aideront à ne jamais l'oublier
john wayne 72 ans
michael manson vient de disparaître et
michael madsen c'est un héros de légende
plus connu sous le nom de john wayne
ainsi après une longue lutte le cow boy
d'hollywood est mort à l'âge de 72 ans
il aura tourné plus de 200 films en
quarante huit ans de carrière c'est john
ford qui l'emploie le premier dans des
films muets un john porte séduit par la
taille en mètre 91 et la prestance de ce
garçon de l'eoa mais c'est raoul walsh
qui lui donne son premier grand rôle en
1930 dans un big three les la piste des
géants où ils jouent pour la première
fois sous le nom de wade
neuf ans plus tard il devient tête
d'affiche à l'âge de 32 ans avec le film
la chevauchée fantastique de john ford
suivront fort apache l'homme qui tua
liberty valance rio bravo et beaucoup
d'autres au total hollywood a gagné
grâce à lui plus de 700 millions de
dollars
celui qu'on surnommait le view
n'obtiendra qu'un seul oscars en 1969 à
l'âge de 62 ans
pour son interprétation du che i fuck
byrne d'entre eux great d'henry hathaway
mais john wayne c'était plus qu'une
idole c'était la conscience des usa est
presque tout le pays s'identifier à lui
qu'il représente un cowboy un officier
de cavalerie ou un soldat de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
d'ailleurs ces rôles et ses déclarations
brutales sur les noirs ou les
communistes son engagement à propos du
conflit vietnamien son soutien à des
homme politiques conservateurs comme ici
richard nixon vive allure l'étiquette de
réactionnaire chaque fois il répondait
c'est faux je suis un libéral aux vieux
sens du terme
j'écoute tous les points de vue et je
dessine moi même les libéraux
d'aujourd'hui exigent que vous acceptiez
leur point de vue c'est pour cela que
j'ai été classé républicain déc
une droite
mais john wayne trois fois marié et papa
divorcé djalminha de faire de cet enfant
dans le voyons ici le lundi 11 avril 79
à los angeles quelques mois après sa
dernière opération attribuée l'oscar du
meilleur film à voyage au bout de
l'enfer ce que les applaudissements ému
de ces années amaigri mais souriant il
déclaré c'est là le meilleur remède qui
puisse mettre à ministère
5 on ressent le sujet et bon voyage au
royaume des grandes prairies